[music]
>> My name is Abby Martin. I'm an American
investigative journalist, founder of the
Empire Files, which is a documentary
investigative series that uncovers the
archives of US imperialism.
You can add some more.
Director of the 2019 Gaza Fights for
Freedom documentary and the director of
the new documentary
Earth's Greatest Enemy that I'm on a
director's for now director's tour
right now in Paris.
Yeah. It's about the US military's
impact on the environment. We maybe we
going to talk about it.
>> I'm very pleased to have you tonight
because we've got a friend in common.
Yeah. His name is Michael Rupert. Oh.
And I would like you to talk to my
community about this guy.
>> [sighs]
>> I mean, I never met him in person. Um I
was always a big admirer of his work, of
course. Um
as someone who uncovered the dredges of
the drug war
and how the CIA was involved in drug
trafficking in low-income communities
in the United States and gave
mind-blowing testimony where he was
indicting high-level figures
in this corruption.
And then he went on to talk about peak
oil, um fossil fuels in a way that no
one really was doing at the time. And he
was
he was an incredible man. Um
and I had a deep connection with him
just because he was really
supportive of my work. Um my journalism
and
he
killed himself.
He committed suicide. Um
and it was a really tough
it was a really tough moment, I think,
for a lot of a lot of us uh because
and I never really I mean, I I did meet
his wife. Um
Actually, on this tour, she came to one
of the screenings and she says, "I was I
was with Michael Rupert when
when we lost him. Um and thank you for
the words that you said when when we
knew that he was gone."
And it was a really
it was the first time that I ever cried
on air. Um you know, as a journalist, I
you know, we're kind of taught to hide
our emotions and keep everything inside
and it was I was so overtaken with grief
finding out that we had lost him.
Um
a true friend and a hero of journalism,
truly.
Imagine he's going to view today about
the war in Iran.
The war in Iran? I mean
back when
>> [clears throat]
>> God, what what what year was it when he
when we lost him? 2000
>> 2014, I think so.
It's been so exposed, the machinery of
all of the naked aggressive belligerents
of US empire. This is what Michael
Rupert was shouting from the rooftops
about. This was this was during the
Obama era.
This was when everything was just
normalized. I mean, look at France
today. This is kind of the sickness of
liberalism. It's the quiet polite
fascism. It's all about decorum and
respectability politics, even though
it's a death spiral.
And Michael Rupert was one of the only
people who was speaking the truth very
frank and open about what we were
barreling into, how it was
unsustainable. It was insane collective
suicide and he was ridiculed
just like so many of us are. We're
marginalized
to the peripheries of of mainstream
media because
we expose the power structures, we're
making people uncomfortable and that's
the kinship that I saw with Michael
Rupert as I I looked up to him. I looked
up to him and I really
what I'm most sad about is that I'm not
able to learn more from him because
today I think that he would have a very
astute analysis about
how horrific uh this new era of
colonialism, which is it hearkens back
to the time of Christopher Columbus
where we're ejecting people at the
barrel of a gun.
Get out of your home
or else.
But at the same time, watching it,
there's this overlap of of the
technological advancement where we can
see the displacement and the genocide as
if it's a reality show.
Tomahawk missiles raining down hellfire
on people
with the complicity of European leaders
allowing this to happen. It's I wish I
could hear from him today. I wish I
could see what he would say because I
feel like it would be the same thing
that I'm saying. And I feel like I'd
have one more ally in the struggle
against this
madness.
You've got to
>> swear?
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, please please you can swear.
You can. Okay. Against this [__]
madness.
Give me some news about United States.
How they feel about the war? How they
feel about the
journalism about what's going on? Mhm.
You've got connection with friends
there.
What do they think?
The United States is a very
contradictory place as
are a lot of places in the imperial core
in the structure of the capitalist
classes in our respective countries.
There's a lot of contradictions because
of the rot of neoliberalism, the
hollowed-out state of journalism,
the infrastructure of the media, the
lack of accountability
for power structures. Um people have a
deep distrust in media and that is why
Trump won.
Trump was the only person addressing
the dysfunction, fake news, fake news.
They lied to us about Iraq, the
propaganda matrix that we all know that
we're a part of. The The vast majority
of Americans know that we've been deeply
lied to. They have a deep distrust of
these institutions and I think that's
similar with so many people around the
world, which is why we see fascism on
the rise because there's a hollowed-out
opposition that doesn't actually provide
anything for people's material reality.
So Trump was the only one siphoning in
that energy and folding it into
right-wing rhetoric and right-wing
media.
So there's a huge problem where there's
a a very big lack of real reporting,
investigative reporting, substantive
reporting. And of course, the richest
men in the world who sit on these boards
that profit off war, they sit on the
boards of the media. They're all part of
the same kind of open conspiracy where
they profit off the destruction, they
cause the destruction and then they lie
to us about what the reality is.
Americans know.
They just don't know how to orient
themselves and they they're starved for
the truth. They just don't know where to
go for it
because everything's being siphoned and
controlled and consolidated in these
such small pockets and it's getting
worse and worse.
And as things become worse
and these things come home to roost,
Americans are becoming more detached
from their material reality. So they're
becoming more detached from
you know, they're becoming they're
becoming susceptible to conspiratorial
frameworks, to cult-like thinking
because it's easier. It's easier than to
deal with with right in front of you.
But um Americans are waking up slowly
but surely.
It's a very tough road ahead um because
we live in a hollowed-out
military empire um and it is
parasitically sucking our life force.
And it's
pouring every last drop of our energy
into a war machine.
And everyone is slowly realizing that
the reason that they can't afford rent
is not because of their immigrant
neighbors, it's because of the
politicians
who are feeding this war machine.
It's a war machine or it's oil company
with an army. Yeah.
It's a oil company with an army? Yes. I
mean, that that's the thing is that the
environmental and climate movements for
the longest time have been pointing
rightfully so to oil companies.
Obviously, they're the biggest
perpetrator of this, right? They are the
ones bribing our politicians. They're
the ones who've set up this
infrastructure to extract pillage,
>> You've got
>> right? You've got proof of bribing of
politician? What's that? You've got some
sources?
>> Uh well, let let me just give you an
example. At COP26,
where I was in Glasgow, Scotland, uh
there was more oil lobbyists there than
there were any country's delegates.
So the whole biggest contingent of the
entire conference was the fossil fuel
industry.
So that just shows you how cartoonish
these these things have become. I mean,
all of these global conferences, they
don't include militarization at all.
They've excluded all emissions from
militaries. And it's because of the
exemption that was led by the Pentagon
back during the Kyoto Treaty in 1997.
So this is where we're at, where we're
obfuscating our reality, where we have
these climate conferences, right? Where
we're paving the Amazon rainforest to
bring delegates there, probably emitting
more carbon than than is saved, where we
don't even talk about what is happening
at them. We don't even point out fossil
fuel. And at the end of the day, what
are we even counting?
We're not even counting emissions.
So what are we talking about here? What
is this?
How about Iran? Do you want Do you think
that the United States go there to
provide democracy for young girls and
freedom?
Or they go there just for oil, gas and
resources, commodities?
Well, I think it's very explicitly laid
bare that it's for oil, gas, natural
resources. It's pillaging and plundering
every last drop. Um, that's what you see
stated by the ruling class. That's what
they're saying today. So, for the last
75 years, I mean, after the after World
War II, it's always been
under the pretense of this kind of
global world order, right? Where rules
apply for everyone, right? Under the
pretense of democracy, human rights.
But, we know that that's always applied
for just the West. It's never applied
for everyone. So, we see the complete
collapse of these institutions, the UN,
NATO. I mean, all these things that are
just ultimately fronts for US power and
the machinery of US empire.
>> international law. International law is
is a complete farce. It's a complete
farce. Look at it today.
Look at it today. Look at the There's
nothing more stark than the hypocrisy
between Russia's war in
in Ukraine
and
than Israel's war in Gaza.
The fact that the media completely
covered for it, the war in Iran.
It's a defensive war, right? What is a
defensive war? What are What are
defensive strikes? The These Orwellian
terms that we just accept and normalize
in the press dutifully, like lapdog
stenographers, just tow the status quo.
And the status quo is actually barreling
us off a cliff. You mentioned oil
companies, right? Oil companies have an
army. That army is US imperialism. That
army is NATO. They are upholding fossil
fuel infrastructure at the barrel of a
nuclear armed gun. They are subjecting
the planet to the confines and dictates
of global capitalism with military power
and force.
And it's time that we point to those
perpetrators instead of the oil
companies as an abstraction. Who's
upholding the system? Who's preventing,
stymieing any sort of
even symbol of defiance to the system.
Look at Cuba. What threat do they pose?
embargo
everywhere in Cuba Yes.
Russian tried to provide them some oil
with tankers
Maybe we will see them arrived.
I don't think so. Go back to Iran.
So, you [snorts] you made any any quest
and a documentary about the pollution
with the military.
Or it's so small.
It's always big.
Tell me more about your documentary
about the pollution that the
United States Army put everywhere.
There's so many layers to this issue.
One of the layers is the fact that we
hear the statistic in academia that the
US military is the world's largest
institutional polluter, bigger than 150
countries. What does that actually mean?
When you look at that statistic alone
and you unpack that, that is just the
oil purchases on paper that the US was
hiding up until a couple years ago
under the pretense again of national
security. You can't know how expansive
our military is because then you would
be feeding information to the enemy,
right?
So, this is this is actually an
incredible premise, but but over time
activists have forced this this
information into the forefront. So, we
know now 270,000 barrels of oil per day.
This is to maintain just the arsenal
of the global military empire. The
amount of toxic chemicals and waste that
that's dumping into the environment
annually just in the US, 20 million
tons.
This is according to all of their own
data on their websites.
The environment the inventory release
of the Pentagon. You can all look and
quantify this yourselves. So, just the
maintenance of the arsenal alone coupled
with
contam- I'm sorry, coupled with legacy
contamination of Agent Orange, nuclear
radiation, extractivism,
then you extrapolate that out and look
at the life cycle, right?
The life cycle, the chain of the
weaponry. How do you extract the rare
earth minerals, right? You you you ship
all these weapons all around the world.
Where are the routes? Where are the
supply chains that the arteries of of
capital flow in the Middle East, where
the oil flows, where the natural gas
pipelines are?
And then you extract extrapolate that
out and then you look at What is the
application of all of this? War.
War. It's unquantifiable. Look at what
we're doing in Iran. Already in the the
first 2 weeks of the war, what BBC
called unprecedented environmental
catastrophic devastation wrought on 90
million people living in the broader
area of that acid rain, black soot,
generational impacts that are going to
be felt globally in just the first 2
weeks. This is collective suicide.
And Trump said it's not the end.
It's not the end. They're going to
intentionally target oil infrastructure
and natural gas infrastructure.
They're going to keep going.
But, it's for freedom.
>> [laughter]
>> Iran has the third largest oil reserves
in the world.
Ever since Mohammad Mosaddegh wanted to
nationalize the oil, he wasn't even a
communist. He just wanted to
independence, he wanted sovereignty for
his people. And that was enough
for the US to completely tamp down and
destroy that country and have it under
its thumb and just sanction the economic
war that's been wrought on Iran ever
since.
Look at Venezuela. Good God, the fact
that the Bolivarian Revolution even
survived
to the to the extent that it has
under just crippling crippling sanctions
where 40,000 people, according to the
Center for Economic and Policy Research,
died
in just a couple years from sanctions.
This is the invisible war. This is the
invisible hand of empire that was
normal, right? Under our respective
governments. This is accepted. This
isn't seen as savage or barbaric to kill
people with sanctions, to deprive them
of food and medicine.
So, it's so obvious, isn't it, what all
of this is for? So, why even placate us
about freedom, human rights, and
democracy? They killed 165 little girls
the first day of this war. Where is the
outrage?
Where? I just read a story where people
are going to the graveyard mourning all
night. This 165 little girls, they're in
just collective disbelief that this
happened. That the US double-tapped a
little girls' school
to kill the the
rescuers. This is war crime upon war
crime, grief upon grief. How do you
process this? This is This is one of the
biggest atrocities
directly committed by the US since the
My Lai Massacre in Vietnam. And yet we
paper over it as if it's just it's all
flattened because of what Israel's done.
The atrocities are so rapid now
that everything's flattened. We don't
even know how to respond
to the most heinous thing.
When you really zoom out and you think,
"Oh my god, that was just 2 weeks ago.
Oh my god, what's next?"
What is your point of view about your
corporation of journalism, so cool
journalism? Did they handle properly the
topics?
Did they made perfect paper or is it
only yellow press everywhere?
propaganda everywhere from
the left side, the right side, the
middle side
What is your point of view about your
corporation of journalism? They they are
making a beautiful job? They are making
an amazing job?
Or they are just like
I don't know how to translate that in
English, but
They they are slave of politicians.
They're slave of empire and capitalism.
In order to ascend in these
institutions, I think in our respective
countries, you need to believe. You need
to dutifully believe in the system. You
need to be a Zionist, an imperialist, a
capitalist through and through. It needs
to be baked in
to the mythos of that underpins
capitalism. And if you are not And if
you are not, you are
relegated to the outskirts. You are
ridiculed. You just need look at my
Wikipedia page. I'm a conspiracy
theorist. I'm I've criticized Israel and
called war crimes what they are. And so,
I must be anti-Semitic. And so, you see
these labels thrown at you.
Um, and and of course, it's reinforced
by corporate media smears because you go
outside the periphery of corporate media
and you're not reinforced by their
narratives. And so, you're cast out.
You're cast out. And that's all they
need to do, right? They just need to
ignore you and not include you in the
conversation. It's like Chomsky said in
Manufacturing Consent. I mean, the the
parameters of debate are so tiny. So, we
have the
imagination that we have, you know, all
the multitude of myriad of media
institutions. We can go and we can look
at liberal conservative media, but
really it's all just
very tightly controlled in just a very
very small What's allowed to be
discussed? Very very small window. And
if you go outside of that, watch out.
Watch out.
It is, you know, the way that the
corporate media works is way more
insidious, I think, you know, as someone
who worked for Russia Today for for
quite some time in the States Say yeah.
in the USA.
And it was called an overt propaganda
network, right? This is the arm of the
Russian state. And you're propagandist
for Russia. And I, you know, I would
acknowledge the bias. Yeah, I'm working
for a station that's funded by the
Russian government. I can acknowledge
that.
>> free there? Yes, very much.
>> free to to work on any topic?
>> 100% 100%. When the incursion of Crimea
happened, I went to my
manager, the bureau chief, and I said,
"I am uncomfortable with the way the
media is telling this story. I feel like
this hearkens back to the Iraq war
propaganda,
Iraqis giving soldiers candy and flowers
and thanking them for coming. And even
if that is true, I feel uncomfortable
towing this line. I I'm an
anti-imperialist and I'm kind of
horrified by military aggression in any
form." He said, "Look, say what you say.
Say what you say."
And I said it. I came I was elevated as
an anti-Russian hero across Western
media overnight. I was on the front page
of French newspapers and British
newspapers saying lauding me,
celebrating me for standing up to the
Russian propaganda network and so I was
invited on all these platforms and
immediately I said, "Well, what about
you?"
Well, I Piers Morgan, I said, "What
about you? This is no different than
what you did during the Iraq war. What
did MSNBC do? What did CNN do?" I went
on NPR and they said, "Uh isn't it isn't
it disgusting that you you know, you're
you're working for an overt propaganda
network that's just completely
propagandistic." I said, "You guys took
a million dollars from you took a huge
I'm not sure if it was a million dollars
it was a very significant amount of
money from BP.
And how could you tell the truth about
the BP oil spill if you are subsidized
by oil corporations yourself? And so
this the way that the corporate media
works is that it is subsidized by the
very corporations that journalists
should be holding to account. These are
the power players that are invested
in the machinery
of the same apparatus that is feeding
the war machine that profits off the
destruction, that tells us the lies.
It's all the same people, it's all the
same system. And when you see things
like Iran or Gaza, it becomes activated,
the manufacturing of consent even though
there might be intrepid journalism
happening on a domestic level.
When it comes to foreign policy, people
become just slaves. The dogma becomes so
entrenched, the patriotism is activated
and you have to tow the line. You have
to tow the line.
And the way the propaganda is
constructed is absolutely cartoonish,
right?
It goes the defensive
Iran is actually the aggressor.
Can you imagine? Starting a war of
aggression. You're already committing
genocide. You're already bombing every
single neighbor and then you start a war
against Iran, right? And the media calls
it a defensive war, a necessary war
because Iran's constructing nuclear
weapons that you claim that were
destroyed weeks prior
in your other attempted war of
aggression.
So, the way that the media manufactures
this, they always absolve the
perpetrator. Iranians and Palestinians
just drop dead while Israelis are
slaughtered, Westerners are murdered.
This is all intentional. Genocide
doesn't happen in a vacuum and war
certainly doesn't happen in a vacuum. It
is told and dictated to us and people
fall prey to that. They have no idea
what's going on. I blame the journalists
for all of this.
You blame them, but
do they do they have got a justice to
make them straight about their
profession? Do they have a
Sermon de hypocrite? Do they have the
Munich Charter to respect?
Do you know the Munich Charter?
The
Do they have any kind of ethical
guidelines in the US for the journalist
corporation?
Well, you know, there was this famous
lawsuit um where Fox News was sued back
like
20 years ago and
they were sued for one of their
extraordinary
claims of disinformation on air and
the judge actually ruled that they're
not a news agency.
And so they're not held to account for
their lies and false information because
they're entertainment. And so you've
seen this kind of invoked over time by
pundits all over corporate media that
no, no, no, we're
Oh, no, no, no, this isn't really the
news. This is just, you know, going back
to that lawsuit and I think that that's
a really instructive case for all of us
because no, I wish there was a
Hippocratic oath that guided journalists
that we all had some
you know, determination for the truth no
matter what cost, right? No matter what
the consequences, but no, entirely
self-preservation and access and
especially in a world where
investigative journalism's dying, it's
dead. Even the Washington Post, it's
seizing in on itself because at the end
of the day it's not profitable, it's not
even marketable to have real journalists
in the country. So, even though the the
underpinning of Americana is about the
First Amendment and the lore of the free
press, it's a dead notion. It does not
exist anymore and very shortly I feel
like the erosion of the First Amendment
it's already where we can't boycott. We
can't boycott Israel. We can't boycott
oil corporations, right? And it's going
to be uh you know, very, very soon. It's
going to be um I would be shocked if the
First Amendment lasted another decade
in its current form.
Tell us about the the evolution of media
in the United States. I mean, these five
last years the audience has been
shifting toward podcast and alternative
media and there's no more audience. I
mean, CNN doesn't have any more viewers.
NPR is nearly dead. Uh CBS is
struggling.
What happened in the United States
during this last five years for the
audience to flew away from mainstream
media and go toward new stuff like I
don't know, Joe Rogan and things like
that. Uh how do journalists react to
this thing?
Well, it started during Clinton um the
Telecommunications Act. I mean, again,
this is all kind of a neoliberal
project, right? Where you you
superficialize and tokenize human rights
and freedom and things that sound really
liberal, but then you're obsessed with
capital accumulation and that's your
basically foundational guiding
principle. And so when that's your
hollowed-out base, people see through
that because it's such a it's such a
hoax. And so when you see these
institutions not holding people
accountable, when they excuse war
criminals like George Bush, when they
parade around Henry Kissinger as some
token you know, uh voice on on the war
on terror, I mean, people see through
that. And they know that there was
something deeply wrong with what we were
told about 9/11, about the Iraq war,
subsequently every one of these foreign
policy misadventures that are done for
the coffers of the very few ruling class
people. And so that distrust continued
to
just fester and fester over time and
they just saw the hollowing out of of
these liberal bodies that dictated these
papers of records, right? These
narratives that we just took as truths.
That was happening at the same time as
the advent of social media. So, this
egalitarian nature of the internet, you
know, the burgeoning consciousness of
people when I was young going into
college and seeing I could the truth you
could seek it out.
Things weren't fed to you. They weren't
forced down your throat. You didn't have
your reality curated to you by tech
overlords telling you, infantilizing
you, telling you what you can and can't
see, who we can trust and who we can't.
Let the think tanks tell us. So, at the
beginning of the internet it was it was
an extremely kind of revolutionary tool.
Over time, obviously, the danger became
very apparent for the ruling class and
they tried to tamp down on that, but at
the same time there was a psyop going on
where they tried to get us to trust in
these institutions like Google.
Spying bad from the NSA, Google good,
Google no evil, trust Google. So, there
was this very like it's been very
manipulative, right? But because we we
all trusted in those institutions in
terms of a counterweight to corporate
media. So, you know, myself included, I
rose to the ranks of independent media,
alternative media trying to use those
tools that they gave to us and now we're
seeing that we're kind of imprisoned in
that same structure. So, the same ruling
class that's consolidating our media is
now consolidating the very tools that we
that liberated us, that reclaimed these
truths and narratives, empowered the
marginalized communities who were
suppressed by ruling class structures
like corporate media the whole time.
Palestinians are a perfect example
reclaiming the truth showing us that
this reality has been inverted. This is
a false reality that's been constructed
and forced down to us. Palestinians are
who we should be listening to to dictate
what the truth is. They just show us the
unvarnished truth livestreamed for all
of us to see. The threat that that poses
is is extreme. So, what used to be six
corporations that controlled 90% of
everything we saw, heard and read a
couple years ago is now tightening even
more, right? Where you see Zionist
billionaires like Larry Ellison
buying up now TikTok um these mergers
happening where you see a genocide
denier
like Barry Weiss who's literally a
Holocaust denier cuz that's what this is
in in Gaza, it's a Holocaust. She is
elevated now to the ranks of which was,
you know, 60 Minutes was one of the last
vestiges of like investigative
journalism in the US and now it's run by
a Holocaust denier.
And she could be running CNN, too.
So, this is the state where you are you
fail up. If you are dutiful, if you're a
good lapdog, if you're subservient to
the empire, you fly up. You ascend to
the tops just like Pete Hegseth, just
like Donald Trump.
The system rewards sociopathy,
psychopaths
and that's why these people are in
power.
And you think something will emerge from
alternative media
that will ultimately replace mainstream
media? I mean, basically
France is in the same kind of situation.
We're a couple of years behind you,
but there's roughly the same distrust
toward mainstream media,
roughly the same distrust toward
journalism and we're seeing a lot of
alternative media just like this one uh
popping up and having really high score
compared to mainstream media. So,
we kind of feel in in France that we're
just behind you. We're
coming
we're going in the same direction which
is not very reassuring. Uh but the the
way the media landscape evolves
is pretty enlightening and the way um
and looking at the American media
landscape and the way it evolves it is a
pretty good signal for us French to
understand what's going on and what's
going to happen to us. Right. Roughly
Donald Trump uh, the the French
government, but seeing that through the
lens of uh, the uh,
transformation of the media landscape is
truly interesting. So, we would love to
see your your view on that.
Yes, I mean, I definitely it's
fascinating here because there's no
First Amendment protections. I mean, the
fact that literally I'm seeing people
get arrested for just saying
very basic campaign slogans for
Palestinian liberation and they are, you
know, this is considered And arrested? I
in the streets of Germany and France. I
mean, Europe is going nuts. I mean, what
is going on here? Um, so so, yeah, I I
just feel like there's there's there's a
lot of contradictions, obviously, with
um, you know, run by a liberal when
there's this much repression on terms of
what you can and can't say in this
country. But, in the States, we still
have the freedom. But, it's so it it's
so
over saturated. That's the problem with
the new media landscape. It is it's so
over saturated and and hyper competitive
because everyone is trying to
garner donations because we're all
competing under this capitalist model
and there's no left-wing billionaires to
fund alternative media.
So, that's, you know, that's I think the
biggest problem right now. But, um,
obviously, I mean, alternative media has
already changed everything. It's already
changed the world. The we see the
propaganda is so desperate and extreme
because, ultimately, Zionism
imperialism, they're paper tigers. They
they only exist because of the weight of
the propaganda and the belief in the
system. And so, once that collapses,
what do we have? we have a chance to
change the world. So, alternative media
is everything and that's why, obviously,
Israel invested so much money into
trying to control and tamp down on these
narratives cuz they see the power of
just the simple truth. Um, but I think
it's really interesting to see channels
like this. Obviously, people are
very attracted to long-form discussions,
right? Not trite
things that are controlled and and and
obviously, what we were talking about
before, the parameters that are very
just stifled and what is acceptable in
these platforms. So, channels like this,
I think, are very refreshing and honest
for people to have long-form analysis
about the geopolitical landscape.
There's a a big topic right now in
France which
is called "ingérence" in France,
which basically is since Donald Trump
came back into power, which is quite
recent,
um,
every politician in France is convinced
that um, Elon Musk, Mark Zuckerberg are
twisting the algorithm in order to
influence French public opinion.
Uh,
what's your take on that?
Who's trying to influence public
opinion? Who's trying to manipulate uh,
social media?
>> saying is?
>> Uh, social networks in order to
influence foreign countries.
You're This is like the whole Russia
gate
Russia gate.
>> yeah, like foreign influence
>> used to be
Russian uh,
trying to interfere in uh,
US public affairs.
>> Mhm.
>> now it's viewed from the French point of
view as Americans trying to interfere in
France public public opinion.
>> Oh, wow. I didn't hear I didn't know
that. That's that's
>> big topic here, but it's quite recent
because
a few days before Donald Trump came back
into power, there was no problem.
>> [laughter]
>> Right. To be totally honest, it started
the day uh, Elon Musk took control of
Twitter. And suddenly, Twitter became a
a tool of influence. Right. Right.
>> what's your take on that? What's the
usage um, from the American power of
social networks, namely Twitter and
Facebook? Uh, and the way they are using
this as a tool for soft power uh,
right now and
before Donald Trump and Elon Musk came
in
came into the scene.
Well, what's funny about that notion is
that what where was the outcry about the
American cultural domination, economic
don- domination and military domination
of the world for the last 100 years?
Like what Like why right now you're just
like, "Oh, America's trying to influence
us through our social media." It's like,
"What about everything else? What about
the the hegemony
of US culture, language? Uh, I should
talk. Um, but I mean, everything. I
mean, good god, the fast food, like the
empty vacuous nature of American culture
that's forced on the rest of the world.
What about that? But, of course, I mean,
the the whole hype about Russian
influence, foreign influence on on
American media, I mean, it is true that
that, of course, the US owns these
social media companies, Mark Zuckerberg,
Jeff Bezos. I mean, it is mostly
American billionaires that are
tightening the control over over social
media and the narratives. But, that's
always the way it has been, right? It's
always been that way. It's just now it's
so much more obvious and I think
Europeans are trying to just kind of
have a degree of separation from what
has always been. But, because it's the
ugly face of Trump and his little
neo-Nazi buddies, like Elon Musk, um,
where we don't call a Sieg Heil a Sieg
Heil.
You cannot say that Elon Musk is a Nazi.
I I said I I can't say he's a neo-Nazi
even though he does Sieg Heil and
and and and all he does is post white
supremacist, white nationalist rhetoric
all day on Twitter and amplifies literal
neo-Nazi accounts.
>> of that?
Uh, just his actual mannerisms and what
he says, the actual rhetoric and his
physical display
of Nazism.
Anyway, nobody's going to sue us for
that.
>> [laughter]
>> Not in France. Everybody's saying the
same thing. Um,
How do you What do you think about the
shift
when it comes to
the American soft power machine shifting
from Hollywood, which is not that
effective these days, to social network?
And the shift it has uh,
it implies into the typically people
like Elon Musk or Mark Zuckerberg
becoming political figure
where
yesterday, Hollywood had the really big
impact on politics and was the main soft
power tool of the American empire.
How do you analyze this shift
when it comes to the American soft power
tool?
I mean, I don't necessarily think that a
Hollywood always had that much I think
it's over inflated. It's because
American culture is so empty that I
think Hollywood is just represented as
some sort of like
pioneering symbol of American culture
and it's over represented in terms of
its influence, I think. Um, because
really who the hell's listening to like
Is anyone determining their politics on
what George Clooney says? I mean, I
don't know. [laughter] I
I would say what's a much bigger
mechanism of US soft power was kind of
the National Endowment for Democracy,
um, USAID. These are the institutions
that have been completely obliterated
under the new era of Trumpism. That I
think is it's it's a dangerous thing to
obviously rug pull institutions that
babies' lives depend on. Although, we
needed to get rid of these institutions
because of what they really were, right?
At the end of the day, they were were
mechanisms to basically foment
revolutionary fervor, um, to remove
countries that we don't like or or
destabilize countries that we don't
like, um, to destroy,
you know, countries that are not totally
subservient, um, to US hegemony. So,
that that has been, I think, the most
interesting kind of advancement that
we've seen is is the total destruction,
again, going back to just
the destruction of the rule of law, this
this collapse of any sort of semblance
that this is about anything else other
than naked a naked resurgence of
neo-colonialism. Tell us more about
USAID because in France,
the only thing we heard was this was a
strictly humanitarian system, nothing
else.
And Donald Trump is destroying it.
There's nothing else to say. Mhm. But,
obviously, if you dig a little, there
was lots of other things going on behind
USAID. And that's something that nobody
knows in France. Right. Nobody knows.
That's fascinating. I mean, USAID has
been used as
a soft power tool ever since its origin.
I mean,
it's been alongside with NED. I mean,
the founder the co-founder of NED
actually said these these institutions
were
basically do what the CIA used to do.
Allen Weinstein, I think, was his name.
I mean, in the New York Times interview
like in '91. I mean, he was basically
just like, "This is This is what has
replaced the need for the CIA
to foment these insurrections around the
world." These institutions under the
pretense of human rights and democracy.
I'll just give you a an example in Cuba,
for example. I mean, USAID was operating
there because it was it was under the
pretense of like vaccine relief, HIV
awareness, right? So, who's going to say
no to that? But, what they were really
doing with those tax dollars were
fomenting like trying to agitate uh,
like hip-hop communities to to, you
know, to rebel against the government.
Um, they were taking data from people
who were just trying to get vaccines or
or help for HIV relief. They were taking
their data and trying to manipulate
them.
Starting a fake Twitter account called
ZunZuneo in the country where they were
taking everyone's data to try to, again,
agitate people, plan an insurrection
against the Cuban government. What on
earth?
That's just the case in Cuba. Good god,
who knows what else they were doing. So,
apply that to everywhere in the world
where they were practicing. And not only
is it just horrific on its face that
you're going far beyond the the aims of
humanitarianism and actually trying to
destabilize countries to put them under
your boot of control, but it it foments
distrust in these institutions from the
respective countries. I remember in
Pakistan, for example, there was a
vaccine program that they were using
through USAID to try to
to try to get Bin Laden or get some
Al-Qaeda figure or something at the
time.
And the people were saying, "We don't
trust you anymore. We don't We're not
even going to get these vaccines because
we're scared that you're CIA." So,
anywhere that there's the soft power
now, anywhere in the world that's you
know into this international diplomatic
mission, people think it's just CIA run,
and they don't trust it anyway.
So, it has been so destructive
on so many
people for so many reasons. I'm all for
humanitarian aid, but this is not what
that agency was.
How come
this was never covered by the the press?
It's the same reason that the true
nature of US foreign policy is not
covered by the press. It's the same
reason why we're treated like goldfish
in a bowl with hallucinogenic collective
memory loss. We have no systemic or
holistic analysis about how we got here,
why we're here, why we're driving
ourselves off a cliff.
You know, the fact that for example, the
Iran war starts or October 7th.
Oh, wow. Every article starts with this
horrific slaughter on October 7th. Well,
what about the 77 years that
precipitated that? What about the 100
children that were killed in the West
Bank the year prior? There's just no
mention at all. These lives are so
devalued and so dehumanized in our
respective countries. When these people
die, they're not even really considered.
It's just about the West. You know, when
when America went and black bagged a
sovereign leader and kidnapped him out
of his home.
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela. We were
told no one died.
100 people died, but no Americans
died.
And that really says it all. The
chauvinist nature of US press and who
they really serve and who they're
dictating to. It's unforgivable.
Do you think the New York Times and
Washington Post will survive this?
>> [sighs]
>> Sadly, [snorts] I mean I I I I want
inshallah. I I I hope that they will
collapse under the weight of their own
complicity.
Um if it were up to me, I would like to
see them, you know,
really charged um with the complicity
for for propagandizing genocide,
manufacturing consent for this. And
that's that's not a precedent that would
be set now. That was a precedent that
was set during Nazi Germany, apartheid
South Africa. There are implications for
media figures. Francesca Albanese is
researching this now in her new report,
the complicity of media and the
culpability of media figures. Um the New
York Times and the Washington Post and
the Wall Wall Street Journal they're
considered literally doctrine.
Especially by the liberal
intelligentsia in the US. Every coffee
shop in Portland, Oregon has the New
York Times out, and it really is the
Bible for a lot of these people. That's
why it's so insidious and dangerous in
terms of parroting imperial propaganda
because people kind of know cartoonishly
Fox News is propaganda and it's
warmongering and this and that, but
people really do think that these things
tell the truth. And it's so so
effective.
Um and I think it will continue to land
for a certain sector contingent of the
population who wants to double down on
the status quo. They want to reinforce
their privilege
because it's such about
self-preservation at the end of the day.
They can't see the forest through the
trees. They can't see what's happening.
So, they'll just continue to read the
New York Times, placate themselves, and
pat themselves on the back for
recycling, and
you know, putting their composting the
green bags, which I do as well. But I
understand without the framework of
internationalism and why this is all
happening, I'm not going to make a
[__] dent.
So, short answer,
inshallah, I wish that they would
collapse, but
the way things are going, I feel like
uh
they're not.
They're going to go to last a bitter
end.
And
And in a few years, well, almost three,
uh
Donald Trump will have ended his second
term.
What will come next? What can come next?
We hope he'll end his second term.
Um I think that there's a lot of trial
balloons going on right now. For a long
time, I thought it was just
hyperbolic anecdotal nonsense that Trump
would do the insurrection act, that he
would maybe not
step down.
But now, I think anything's possible.
Um I think anything's possible. I think
that ICE in the streets was another
trial balloon. I didn't think they
expected people to come out in their
bathrobes in sub-zero temperatures um
facing down ICE agents after they
executed their brothers and sisters in
the streets. So, that was something that
I think kind of scared and shook them a
little bit. The talk of a national
strike,
the hundreds of thousands of people that
were out in Minneapolis in the days
after that to really shut down their
businesses and ICE left.
Um so, there's trial balloons being
tested. They're trying to figure out
what they can get away with, what they
can do. Um and the wars always come home
to roost obviously for marginalized
people, but I think it's it's becoming
very, very uh potent now. When you see
someone like Pete Hegseth saying, "We
need $200 more in emergency funds as we
can't We don't have health care. We
don't have child care. People are just
dying in the streets. We're stepping
over bodies, and this is what we're
using our resources for."
What's going to come next?
I don't see a liberal opposition.
I see a continuous doubling down,
tripling down
in status quoism. Um I don't see anyone
who can offer
an avenue that's contrary to what Trump
is is delivering. I mean, Kamala lost
because of Gaza. That's proven now. That
was in a postmortem electoral result.
Um so so, Trump
they're going to continue to just feed
off the energy. They're going to
continue to try to amplify these false
culture wars. Um I think if J.D. Vance
comes next, it's going to be the same. I
don't think we're going to have another
figure like Trump.
But Trump has bred a whole new
generation of people who could just
carry on this legacy of Trumpism, which
is the neo-fascism.
And the liberals have just hollowed out
any sort of semblance of anything that
we can do institutionally to stop this.
What do you think of Peter Thiel?
I'm going to I'm going to Well, Peter
Thiel, uh you know, where is he right
now? He's in the Vatican trying to
debate the Pope about how
Greta Thunberg is the real Antichrist,
right? That's his whole Oh, man, what a
what a fascinating lecture that would
be.
Um look, these people are very detached.
They have god complexes. They are so I I
don't know if it's just severe autism or
like a crazy detachment from reality,
but they they are so detached from what
the consequences of their actions. Um
Peter Thiel is
he is funding He's sitting not only in
the shadows. I mean, he's out there
obviously doing these bizarre lectures
about the Antichrist. He's kind of
incorporating this religiosity
into his god complex, which I kind of
kind of think is even more fascinating
and scary because he really If we want
to look at someone who has the levers of
power,
right? AI.
All of the Silicon Valley, the PayPal
Mafia people, these people
they have no safeguards on their AI.
They're barreling through all of these
systems, integrating it with the war
machine.
Where is this going? It's not going
anywhere good.
So, Peter Thiel is one of these main
operators who seeded our reality. He has
He For the last 20 years, he's funded
everything All the power has been
siphoned into the right-wing
stratosphere, and that is a Thiel
operation. He's not only behind Trump.
J.D. Vance is a Thielite. Right? J- J.D.
Vance is a basically incubated in a
Thiel factory. I mean, he is a puppet of
Peter Thiel. That is why he's a relevant
person. He worked for Peter Thiel. He
His whole campaign was funded by him.
So, Peter Thiel has not only a direct
line just to the White House, but
the entire infrastructure of this. The
infrastructure of genocide, the
infrastructure of the surveillance
system
of ICE, of everything in our respective
countries. Peter Thiel
is behind all of that. So, it's a very
dangerous display, and again, totally
unregulated.
Going back to artificial intelligence,
there've been some
things going on between Anthropic
>> Mhm. and OpenAI when it comes to
powering the Pentagon.
And clearly Anthropic has said, "Okay,
this is going to far. We're
stopping here."
And OpenAI jumped in and said, "Oh,
we'll do it. No problem."
>> Yeah.
How do you feel that
the role
artificial intelligence is going to play
in the war
in general? It's playing right now.
It has the
Go back to Julian Assange a little bit.
Artificial intelligence has been popping
up during the the war in Ukraine, and
it's playing a big role.
It has a major part uh
in the war in
in Gaza.
And today in Iran, it's
everything is turning around artificial
intelligence. It has definitely changed
the way we do war. This and drones Mhm.
have definitely changed the way we do
war. How do you feel? How do you analyze
this? Mhm. I remember when dro- drone
warfare became the forefront of
obviously the the war on terror with
Obama at the helm.
And it [clears throat] And it was just
so disturbing, the fact that you could
have this kind of lack of
accountability. It's like a video game,
quote unquote, that a lot of these drone
operators said. And of course, the 98%
failure rate um according to the
Pentagon itself about their official
targets weren't even met when they
deployed the drones. So, it it was
always just so perverse of an operation
that you can be, you know, so far away
in operating base and kill kids Um and
have and never look in their eyes
and never see who you're murdering. And
now, you don't even have a person. It's
just a computer. It's Claude.
It's Lavender.
It's Hey Daddy or whatever that system
was in Gaza where you just plant in
an operational system of phone numbers
and whoever exchanged around a phone and
whoever's in the vicinity of potentially
someone who worked in the government who
was who picking up the trash, who did
the mail
all of their neighbors and friends could
be blown up in these AI
targeted strikes. So So it First of all,
there's a contradictory element to it
which is AI is supposed to be really
intentional and targeted, right? And it
And it And hone in exactly with no
mistakes. So how is that possible that
you could have something that is so
specific and so targeted but at the same
time be carpet bombing entire
neighborhoods and
destroying whole high-rise buildings
where it looks like 9/11's are happening
every day in Iran and Lebanon and and
Palestine. How is that possible?
So there's this just horrific nature of
of the destruction, the wanton
destructions and war crimes that there's
no culpability. It's the plausible
deniability of the AI.
So even if there was some sort of
semblance of international law, even if
we did see these charges that were
manifest by the ICC and we see Netanyahu
holding trial, who would even take
responsibility for this? The computer?
The AI? So this is the dangerous
slippery slope we're going on. When you
couple that in with processing speed of
how things can happen
the nature of warfare is going to get
very, very scary. We think it's scary
right now, it's just going to get
scarier.
Um [snorts] but I look at something like
this is the way everything is operating.
It's not just warfare, it's
Look at healthcare. I mean United United
Healthcare with Brian Thompson the CEO
who was gunned down in New York and
that was the way that they implemented
their entire system was the AI would
decide if you could live or die. The AI
was the arbiter of of your life if you
were worthy of getting an insurance for
these things when you take out the human
element? Who?
We're not operating with human beings
anymore.
How about journalism? AI is coming big
time in journalism.
>> Yeah.
What do you think will happen uh when AI
will will take you
find its way into journalism, into the
the intimidation between readers and the
news? Mhm. Just today made by the media
and journalists, but obviously AI has
some role to play in that. Of course. I
mean you mentioned before this notion
that the US is manipulating social media
and foreign influence meddling and
things like, you know, Russia and French
media and stuff like that to shift
public opinion.
What about corporations? What about AI?
The dead internet is here.
Nothing that we see is really real. I
mean it is such a false construct. I
Half of what you're seeing are bots, are
AI. I mean the oversaturation and
overinundation of of algorithmic
nonsense to bolster certain narratives
whether it corporate or state um is
going to be completely indistinguishable
from reality. And then you couple in
deep fakes,
right? Um fake videos. I mean you even
see Donald Trump's official White House
account putting out literal staged
photographs
of a woman crying when in fact she was
pretty defiantly arrested, um proud
black woman. And she's sitting there,
you know, looking hysterical crying
because of this deep fake that they put
out of I mean that that is such a dark
war that is being waged on our minds
um that AI is just going to further
exacerbate the darkness, the just
completely pulverize everything that we
know to be true. And so I think that
journalists have a very, very tough road
ahead, but they have it's a very serious
job. Critical media literacy and
figuring out what the hell's true in
this world. And that means not reacting
immediately to everything until you
realize if it's [__] real.
Go back to your documentary. Yes. It's a
long one, a short one, a medium one? How
long?
5 years. 5 years long, yeah. Started it
during COVID when I realized that the
system had completely failed and that
the Imperial Core where I was living um
had the biggest death rate in the world.
You made it in the
whole Oh, sorry.
How long you How many weeks you took to
to make it? It's months, weeks, years?
>> 5 years.
>> You made You made it in 5 years? Yeah, 5
years.
>> a little bit around?
>> Yes. Yes, Japan, Guam,
um all over the United States. So just
different pockets of of US military
destruction across the US and around the
world in Glasgow, um Iraq.
And that's, yeah, Alaska. Who financed
that? Who gave you the money to make it?
Where do you get Where do you get the
money?
>> Peter Thiel. No, just kidding. That's
Just joking.
Um
There's [clears throat] no way it's a
part of truth.
>> [laughter]
>> So, you know, this kind of journalism
doesn't It's not marketable. It's not
financed. There's no institutional or
celebrity backing for it. It was all
crowdfunded. We did
>> everything? 500,000.
Yeah, 500,000 US. And I'm still looking
for three 30,000 more licensing costs
before we could put it up online
streaming
because the quality is as the people who
saw it can agree, it's very you know, I
didn't I I wanted like the best possible
quality and I didn't settle for anything
less. And so you I wanted people to sit
down and watch it and think that they
were watching the quality of something
like Top Gun, which I don't know if I
did, but
it's it's it's a pretty devastating
movie and I think we I think that we
proved the case
that the US military, not just the US
military, but US imperialism, the entire
machinery of global capitalism that
wields the machinery of US empire,
that is what our biggest enemy is. That
is what is imperiling all life on Earth.
Did you receive some of the threats or
did you receive some pressure from the
US government? They call you and say,
"Happy, you go too far now."
Take it easy.
Did you receive some threat? So they
just don't answer you. That's the thing.
I tried to get an official sit-down of
Pentagon officials because I'm not
accredited through a corporate media, an
official legitimate institution like the
New York Times, you don't really get
into these spaces.
Um and so
I was just chasing these people down. I
had to go into their spaces and hound
them and chase them down. And
you know, what's funny about the movie
is that it's kind of like a hive mind of
evil. Everyone is compartmentalized.
Everyone has cognitive dissonance of
what even they're doing, but all of them
just say, "We need We just need the oil.
We need the oil. We need the minerals.
We need the minerals." And then you ask
them just point-blank. I asked one of
the former NATO commanders. I said,
"Well, Which one?
Um Was it Clark? No, no, no, no, no. No,
I forget his name. Um
But I I asked him, you know, what what
are these interests that you're
protecting around the world?
What are they?
And And I said, "Well, And what gives
you the right to say that we need
superiority over the Arctic?" And he was
like, "I never said that." He was just
in a panel that was literally called
Arctic Dominance, US Dominance over the
Arctic. So it's like you you talk to
these people. I talked to a woman at a
weapons contractor.
I talked to a weapons contractor at one
of these conferences and I was like I
was I'm doing a documentary about US
militarism and the impact on climate
change. She was like, "That sounds
political."
That sounds political. And I was like,
"You sell weapons that kill kids and
you're telling me that
your your job Your job isn't political?"
So it's just this kind of bizarre
abstraction of what are we even do The
people who are operating even in the
heart of the system.
And they can just justify it themselves.
>> to this guy, what was your inner voice
saying?
>> [laughter]
>> I was so mad.
I was so mad. I mean my inner voice was
just saying,
"How do you not see?" I mean I I
remember talking to another guy with one
of had a giant drone in front of him
that it, you know, they're polishing
making it look all good.
"Did you ever think about who's on the
receiving end of these weapons?" No.
I just clock in, clock out, do the R&D,
do the research and development, and go
home.
I mean, what do you say?
What do you say to these people?
Am I supposed to appeal to your basic
empathy? Say, "Have you seen
what these bombs are doing to shred
babies' bodies apart in Gaza? Do you
want Do you want to see? Do you want to
sit down with me and I can show you?"
Like what What do you say?
What I've realized over the course of my
career, Yeah, they told you, "Yeah, but
most of the time is terrorism. We shoot
the terrorist.
Sometimes there is collateral damage."
Did they say
>> even say that anymore.
It's impossible to to to rationalize
because we see the truth.
We see everything. I've been watching
genocide for 3 years. I know what what
collateral damage is and what it's not.
I know when you
when you when you
drop the equivalent of what, five
nuclear bombs
into an area that's uh the most densely
populated place in the world, that's not
collateral damage. That is intentional
wanton destruction. That is genocidal
intent. That is genocidal destruction
according to the very definition. Um so
it you can't even claim these things. If
you claim these things, you're denying
reality. And then we're talking about
something else entirely where you
literally are on a different plane
of believability and
Where I I don't know how I can connect
with you as a human being if you don't
see what's right in front of your eyes.
See what you see. Don't be duped. See
what's right there.
What was the the toughest part of your
documentary that people told you that
put that on here is going to be too
much?
Well, the toughest part was was honestly
trying to get this the Pentagon's
official response. And what's amazing
and revealed in the documentary
>> [gasps]
>> is that they have an actual division
called the Media Entertainment Office in
Hollywood where they they
grant you interviews if This is what I
was told in a in a
I'm sorry. If you kneel. If you kneel.
If you put your knee. If you give them
the script, if they have editorial
control over the project, if they can
dictate what you are saying about them.
So, this is what I was told. This was
even admitted to me by one of their
liaisons, a Marine liaison who worked
for the entertainment media division. He
said that he went there and then started
going and lobbying to SAG events and all
these industry events in Hollywood and
saying, "How can we get the military
more in a motion pictures?" And he says,
"And boom." And you see over the next
10 years, it's like boom boom boom boom
boom. It's like every single movie all
of a sudden you see just this wave of
military propaganda. So, this is a very
concerted effort. But what's amazing and
what I didn't realize is how it's also
applied to documentary films. It's not
just motion pictures. Documentary films
it works the same way. If you want an a
military official to give their response
or have a sit-down interview, you need
to feed them the whole script and they
need to approve it.
Did you did you took some former
military
guys?
Former guy who were are not in charge
anymore?
>> Yes.
>> ready to talk about your topic or not?
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I mean the the thing
about the documentary is it's mostly
told through whistleblowers and veterans
themselves.
Um my husband is an Iraq War veteran who
is now a whistleblower about the war in
Iraq and so
he
you know, he's kind of this humanistic
element where that's what we're trying
to make sure is it's not about soldiers.
We understand that people are all
victims of the system and they're all
victims of military pollution because it
has no borders.
But there's so many whistleblowers in
the documentary who talk
for example, there's two really
interesting revelations. One of them is
an institutional practice that goes on
in the Navy
um while they're at sea is that they
process the plastic, melt it all down
into these massive like pizza-sized um
discs and they throw them over
into the ocean. And this is something
that's been happening for decades. This
is corroborated by at least 30
um
ranking people who have been just
low-level and high-ranking naval
officials. Um this is an institutional
practice that they dump everything
overboard.
And that it's it's
if you don't do it, you're hazed. It's
like a hazing ritual and everyone does
it and they've always done it. So, just
that kind of callous disregard for the
sanctity of life in the ocean
um what they do to just engage in
warfare against marine mammals all the
time. Um one of the one of the
whistleblowers told me that they would
hit whales and not even log them.
Um that it took him two days straight
just to dump the amount of trash that he
was ordered to of shifts of that's how
much trash was on board. I mean
the amount of waste
just by munitions because basically the
the entire way that the military is run
is like a for-profit corporation. It's
the military-industrial complex, right?
So, in order to make this more money the
next year, otherwise you'll lose your
profits, you have to get more equipment.
You have to invest in the next
generation. Yeah, so for example, the
F-35 or the Bradley fighting vehicle and
all these the next generation the next
gen nukes, right? You have to constantly
fortify and create new iterations of
weaponry that's perfectly fine, right?
Bullets don't expire after a year.
But because you need to justify the
spending this out-of-control spending,
you what they do is they actually blow
up all the munitions on site
and drain all the oil so they don't take
it with them back to their forward
operating base. So, then they can say we
need more.
And this is a totally
institutionalized thing everywhere. And
[snorts] and then of course, they give
all the surplus military equipment, you
know, goes in the hands of ISIS or
Al-Qaeda or you look at um local police
forces across the US. They're constantly
militarized because there's nowhere else
to go with this equipment. I mean,
that's the self-eating nature of the
machine.
Once you
once you take everything it it has to go
somewhere. So, it goes internal.
Um and so that's what we're seeing now.
Do you want to
speak about a a topic that you want?
Mhm. Tell me any topic that you want to
speak.
>> [sighs]
>> I mean, I just can't It's really hard to
wrap your mind around what's going on in
Gaza, isn't it?
Gaza and now Lebanon and Iran and
>> [sighs]
>> This is the beginning of the World War
III?
This is the third world coming?
The thing about it is that I feel like
it's been we're been on we've been on
the precipice of this kind of
of World War III. I mean, it's been
happening, right? The economic war, the
the domination of of all these
narratives. It's been it's been in the
background and just that the kind of
that slow burn, the slow militarization,
the offuscation of the nature of what
this is, the the constant expanse, the
the drive it almost seems like it's an
inevitability, right? Because there's no
imagination outside of what we are been
what we've been told. War with Russia,
war with China. As we face down these
massive crises that we need to
collaborate with the planet on.
Um so, that's what just kills me
is all these people invoking God and
religion. It's like we have never been
further from what our natural world is.
Like what we what what makes us human.
Why we have humanity.
So, you've got three books for my
community to read.
What kind of books you can advise to my
community? Give me three names. Mhm.
I mean, I am a I am an Octavia Butler
head.
Um
I mean, I I would have said Noam Chomsky
before the Epstein thing, but
Another one bites the dust, huh? No, I
mean, I'll never throw the work under
the bus. Um Michael Parenti. I mean, I
Project Censored.
What was your point What is your point
of view about the Epstein file?
Mhm.
That's a big broad one. I mean, I mean
the
>> [laughter]
>> I mean
the Epstein files, I mean
Epstein was clearly an asset working for
a hybrid intelligence, yeah? Which one?
Um I mean, I'll say Mossad and CIA. This
this evidence is now like completely
clear from the Epstein files themselves.
One need to just just do a quick search
and you can see that he was reporting,
he was meeting with several high
high-level intelligence officials in the
Israeli government. I mean, it would
Barack was like a frequent guest at all
of his penthouses. Um and then of
course, Bill Clinton, Trump, they were
all very close friends. I think the
Epstein file is it's it's obviously
we're getting we're getting seeds
Really?
close with Epstein. He's been close to
Trump. Oh, yeah. Oh, they were best
friends in the '90s. Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Oh, yeah. Um Trump said
I mean, there's there's
he's in more photos and videos with
Epstein than I am with like some of my
own family members. I mean, this this
guy the amount of material out there. I
mean, just the
the bizarre letter that he wrote
outlining like a little girl's body
writing like very coded weird creepy
[__] I mean, it is like they might as
well have just been like, "Hey, I had
fun like with those little girls last
night." I mean, it's it's so obvious
that they were disgusting pigs that were
assaulting women. I mean, grab him by
the grab them by the [__]
This is a man who said he grabs women by
the [__] So, this is our president. Um
this is this is the ruler of the
military empire. So, yeah, of course he
was good friends with Jeffrey Epstein
and there's this kind of notion that he
stood up to Jeffrey Epstein, kicked him
out of his Mar-a-Lago look Mar-a-Lago
What are hotels used for? I mean, come
on. All of this is just part of this
machinery, a blackmail operation. But
then what's interesting about the
Epstein files is that it goes into this
weird territory where it absolves Trump
and pretends like Israel's blackmailing
him into doing all the things he's
doing. And that is an odd
pivot from the truth because I don't
like to absolve the US empire. I don't
like to absolve Trump.
Go back to the three books. Give me
three name of books
to advise.
The Veins of Latin America. Um I mean,
Blowback was one that was really
formative for me.
Um Confessions of an Economic Hit Man.
These are all like really form I would
say like formative books on
understanding the the like the
machinations of US imperialism at least
for me when I was younger growing up.
Um
The the Blowback was an amazing one
because I remember reading that from
Chalmers Johnson. He was a former CIA
guy turned anti-imperialist. And there's
a whole chapter just on Okinawa. And I
was completely blown away that this
former CIA guy could be like, "Oh, this
is I mean, to to know that an island
smaller than the state of Rhode Island
which is
such a tiny little land, right? With 32
military bases on this tiny island and
it harbors the most ancient beautiful
blue coral reef, all these endangered
species, hundreds of endangered species,
the dugong whale which is an icon for
Japanese Okinawan people. And we're
we're over there. My military is over
there expanding, destroying in this
exercise in just complete futility and
insanity, just blowing up this mountain,
landfilling this beautiful blue ocean.
And um
I just couldn't believe it. I couldn't
wrap my mind around the insanity of
this. And that a former CIA guy was
sounding the alarm on this saying, "This
isn't for security. This isn't for
anything. This is just sheer destruction
for profit."
So, I think there was something about
that that that burst through my
understanding of like just my whole
notion of American exceptionalism, that
this was somehow about freedom and
protection. And I just thought, "Whoa,
whoa, wait.
This is insane. Like the the this is the
opposite of everything I've been told."
And that was when I was 18.
Have you got an advice for the next
young generation?
Oh, wait. Let me give two more books.
End of Ice by Dahr Jamail and Green Zone
by Barry Sanders. These are two books in
the film that um are really crucial
reading. The Green Zone by Barry Sanders
is basically a cumulative kind of thesis
on on that underpins our film. So, we
kind of refreshed his thesis from 20
years ago. But he was the first person
that I know that really calculated the
environmental impact of the military in
a comprehensive way. The End of Ice by
Dahr Jamail um is a great one that
really accounts for how cataclysmic
climate change is coming. Um and really
an honest sobering look at it that I
never really wanted to look at before.
And I love him because he's a war
reporter. And so, he understands
militarism and the role that it plays.
And I really appreciate that perspective
in terms of the climate debate. Because
that's what this movie is trying to do.
It's trying to intervene in the
environmental movement. We're trying to
have an intervention
in this mainstream dialogue where the
onus is on us
to have paper straws, solar panels, and
Teslas
without pointing to the big chemical
polluters, the big institutional
polluters, the ones who are
creating single-use Styrofoam and making
us feel like it's our fault
that we can save the world if we just
buy right. No. Um so, this is this is an
intervention to stop this madness, to
have us honestly reflect on what we can
do. Because me drinking out of a paper
straw is not going to do anything unless
we collectively act together and point
to the real perpetrators of this
disaster.
Um and all of it's been a marketing
tool.
The hope that I see in the future is the
consciousness that's exploding around
the world, the millions of people in
sustained action everywhere that are
putting their careers and lives on the
line in some instances.
>> few number of people would do that,
who've done that. There's a few, but all
it takes is a few.
That's all it takes. History changes
quickly. Look how much history's changed
in the last
2 months.
It seems like years, decades have
passed. That's how quickly we can do
things. That's how much agency people
have to change the world.
>> work? If it doesn't work, we tried.
Sure as [__] tried, didn't we?
We gave it a go.
Cuz you know what? I'm not going to sit
idly by and let fascists just take over
and let them kill and rob my planet. I
brought two children in this world. I
have a vested stake in the habitability
of the future of this planet. I love the
earth. I love people. That's everything
that I know and my community is movement
building, having a stake in in every
everything, every living breathing thing
on this earth. I'm not going to [__]
let these monsters rob it from me blind.
And at the very least, I'm going to
speak the truth
as much as I can and give us a fighting
chance. And that's why I spent 5 years
doing this to to just give us a fighting
chance, give us a tool
that we can at least know. Because you
can sit down and and have 20 books,
right?
The problem with the way media works
today is people don't have the attention
span they need to just sit and actually
process good information. And I do
believe media can change the world. I
really do. And I think look
for the past 20 years, the the word
socialism, communism, it's been
completely taboo in the the capitalist
core, right? In the imperial core.
Now, it's not. We understand the
foundational enemy. We understand that
capitalism is driving this.
That gives me hope. I triple down on
that. So, the population
>> to.
The population start to understand
what's going on.
What's going to be the reaction of the
system?
They're going to defend themselves.
They're going to be aggressive
against the population or against the
new type of media?
They're desperate now. We see how
they're lashing out because they're like
a dog in a corner. And they're lashing
out because they know they've lost.
They've lost the consciousness.
Zionism's lost the consciousness.
All they know how to do is kill
kill, murder, displace, lie. None of
these are viable, winnable strategies.
Um history is no longer dictated by
the ruling class. It's history is no
longer dictated by just the ones that
are in power. We understand now.
We we've formulated and and reclaimed
our reality. And we're going to act
accordingly.
There is inquiry in United States
against the Epstein file or
do someone has been in front of a judge
for that? No.
So, you're living in a dream.
>> [laughter]
>> No? Well, [clears throat]
look.
Yeah, I'm
>> everything ever happen, though? But
yeah, you could we were in abject
slavery. I mean, Jim Crow.
You know, none of these things are
spontaneous. None of these things are
just extemporaneous on a whim. They take
long, boring planning, organizational
support. And they take years.
Years of boring conversations, strategy,
tactics. None of this just comes
overnight. And the thing is, of course
we're not going to fight the military
empire with military force. Of course,
violence can never beat these people.
They run a global military dictatorship.
So, what can stop them?
Shutting down capital.
Shutting down the arteries of what
speaks to them the most, money. That's
all that matters to them. That's why
Minneapolis worked. That's why it
terrified them. Look at all of the labor
struggles. That's why they hollowed out
unions. They co-opted labor. The
environmental movement, the feminist
movement, all of these rights that were
were gained from mass popular
mobilizations were co-opted and
superficialized in a neoliberalism. But
now we understand that because that's
been exposed. So, now we have a a
regenerative opening. The mass
consciousness, the young people in
America. This is not just anecdotal
through my own
meetings. This is through polling. This
is through research. We understand where
the public sentiment is now with Gen Z,
with young people, especially in the
Democratic Party base.
Zionism is untenable. You're not
progressive if you're a Zionist. Now,
it's becoming untenable to be an
imperialist if you consider yourself an
environmentalist. And that's great.
Because these are the systems, these are
the structures that we need to
incorporate in the framework of our
political system. And it starts with us.
We have to build a power block. No one
wants a bloody revolution in the
streets.
We don't want that. What we want is a
power block where we can force the hands
of power and make them concede to our
demands. We must. We have no other
choice.
>> It's not too late.
>> It's not too late. Every day is better
than what's coming.
Just like Dahr Jamail said early on in
the Iraqi occupation, they had a saying,
"Today is better than tomorrow."
And that's what we say when we think of
climate change, when we think of where
we're all headed with the integration of
AI,
this new tech dystopia, the global
military dictatorship, all of us living
under the boot. It's going to get worse
unless we
stop it.
Give me again a new advice for the young
generation.
An advice for the future for them, for
your child, maybe.
Don't try to be
something that you're not. Be true to
yourself. Get off your phone
and live life. And that means
don't be paralyzed
by what is being shown to you on a
device.
Okay? Go out and start talking to people
and looking them in the eye.
Feeling the empathy, getting back to the
human level
of when you can talk to someone and meet
them where they're at with humility.
That's a beautiful thing. So, first and
foremost, we need to start living life,
getting out of these silos, right? And
this depressive state where everything
is paralyzing and terrifying.
We have agency.
And they know that we do. If they
didn't, they wouldn't be doing what
they're doing to tamp down on what we
can and can't say, what we can and can't
do.
So, my advice to young people
is to live, baby. Live. Breathe the air.
Go out in nature and love. Love with
your full heart. And that means
fighting.
Fighting for something that's bigger
than yourself. That's what life is. It's
not about us.
It's not about me. It's not about you.
It's about believing in something that's
bigger than us.
Abby Martin, thank you.
Thank you so much for having me. It was
so wonderful to be on. Appreciate you.
>> [music]
[music]